joining me now Newt Gingrich former
speaker of the house and Fox News
contributor new there's a couple things
going on here number one the rules never
apply to them they never have to live
with the Carnage and the ruin that their
policies create because they kind of
float above it but they were caught here
weren't they
they work hard and frankly my favorite
wasn't on the island although I do think
with Barack Obama's I think 29 acre
estate he could easily have hosted
everybody there had a nice picnic
allowed them to camp out but the one I
liked even more was the bus the two bus
loads arriving at Kamala Harris's vice
presidential residence just shortly
after she announced on NBC news that the
border is secure uh you know the the
irony
of how totally dishonest she is and the
fact that uh Governor Abbott did a great
job between Governor Abbott and Governor
DeSantis I feel like Republicans are
back on offense and are finding a way to
break through the media because this was
so vivid in both places that actually
the mainstream media found itself having
to cover it uh delicious yeah I mean
finally Republicans are producing events
rather than just talking at people you
know releasing statements or multi-part
plans that's fine it's not nothing wrong
with that but when you create events
that are newsworthy they have to cover
them and then all of a sudden uh you see
split screens with you know the truth
happening on one side and then a bunch
of angry liberals on the other well Newt
um I tried to um I need to play
something this was from Biden last night
where I think if you listen closely he
basically gave up the game
historic American Rescue plan helped us
emerge on the pandemic and move from
economic crisis to Resurgence it helped
to safely reopen our schools in absolute
necessity including 28 percent of public
school students who are Latino 28
they're all going to own the country man
we better down well make sure they have
every opportunity they have not a joke
well Newt someone who happens to love
um Hispanic Americans is myself since my
daughter's from Guatemala but uh they
get upset when you say there's
demographic change going on and this is
a replacement people don't like that
language I get it's fraught with all
sorts of things but he's kind of in a
way referencing that in that comment
well he is but you know the amazing
thing is because most Latino families
believe in the work ethic because they
care about take-home pay because they're
aware of the cost of living crisis we're
living through and because they have
core values that make them really angry
about a lot of the left-wing woke ideas
uh you're seeing a larger and larger
number of Latino Americans vote
Republican so I think you know whatever
the Democrats theory was uh their their
total failure to deliver the fact that
it just isn't working is costing them
votes in every Community
African-American Latino American Asian
American as well as traditional white
Americans because you look around you go
to the grocery store you look at the
price of Cheerios and you know it just
isn't working and I think that's the
great problem and it's why I still
believe there's going to be an amazingly
big Republican Victory this fall yeah I
think the Hispanics I mean again using
their their fraught language they're
actually going to replace the Democrats
because they're voting Republicans so
I don't think they know what they're
they're kind of mixed up and how they're
trying to analyze this as usual
um today on MSNBC news they were
discussing one of the so-called
solutions that the Biden Administration
is looking at here watch
there are DHS officials who are going to
meetings called at the White House
pretty regularly now where they're
looking at these numbers as they're
going up they're coming up with
Solutions some of them include busing
migrants from the border into the
interior but not in a way where you
would surprise a community like this in
Martha's Vineyard
now it's only bad when they go to
Martha's Vineyard because it affects the
elites and the elites like to talk about
caring about immigrants but in the end
they just want to deport them vote them
off the island
look what she just said is a total lie
they have been flying people around
bussing people around sending them
around by train and not telling local
authorities they've been landing at
night in places like Westchester uh the
fact is that you've had two million
people across the border illegally under
Joe Biden and they didn't all stay in
South Texas they're all over the country
uh and in fact what what's bothering I
think the Democrats is that you now have
a couple Governors who are making sure
the public understands what has actually
been going on anyway and remember this
is in the middle of a crime epidemic on
a scale we have never seen not even in
the 70s Philadelphia this year will have
the highest murder rate in its history
Atlanta now has a higher per capita
murder rate than Chicago and of course
in Chicago which is a huge crime problem
uh the people in the the Democrats in
the state legislature just voted to end
bail for cash so you're going to be
turning out criminals back on the street
in a way that you have to wonder are
these people just crazy because it's not
just political I mean this is not about
being a radical leftist this is about
being nuts yeah and the driving
businesses out of Chicago too as we know
with McDonald's now raising uh raising
the red flag uh finally Newt NBC News is
reporting today that Biden aides are
quietly assembling a 2024 campaign as
they await final decision on his
political future new they're trying to
avoid the lame duck label but Biden 2024
bumper stickers are they um ready to be
plastered all over cars across America
listen I if I were the Republican
candidates I would be Plastering Biden
2024 stickers as fast as I could get
them I think every uh candidate running
on the Democratic ticket you know I
think it's a Biden Warnock ticket it's a
Biden fetterman ticket uh it's a Biden
Mark Kelly ticket uh let's all let's see
how many of them want to actually try to
defend Biden as I said a minute ago you
have a huge problem in the price of food
the price of gasoline when heating oil
prices go up in New Hampshire in New
Hampshire in October I want to see how
Senator Hassan answers that so I I think
uh the Biden you know but look you're a
paid staff you're hanging around you got
nothing better to do why not invent a
Biden 2024 bumper sticker uh it would be
could have a little kind of a frowny
face uh because that's how the country
will react to it hope and deranged all
right Newt great to see you tonight as
always thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else